knight f6
let's play the king's indian defense
and i know why it's called the king's
indian but i'm not gonna tell you
because that knowledge
is something i learned very recently
and i was so inspired and
surprised to learn why kings indian is
called king's indian and the nimto
indian called him to indian
and the boko indian called bogo indian
i was so surprised to learn that
at such a late point in my career that i
feel it would be
under sealing it if i would just tell it
to you on this banter blitz
stream i'm going to save it for
for a better occasion
but it is an interesting thing to think
about guys why is
why are all the d4 openings called
basically indian defenses
something that you should all know
something you don't
well we forgot to talk about this game
well uh what we should actually say
that the way my opponent plays is
something magnus would have never done
because
you do not invite the benko volga
sacrifice
of b7b5 which i'm about to execute let
me do it here for
instructiveness sake you do not allow
that
with the king on the queen side of
course this is going to happen anyway
even with the king on the on the king
side it would be
quite promising for black but now with
the king right
you know on the queen side where the
open files are gonna be
this is really um inviting i'm getting
trouble
and f4 is a
clever attempt to stop 95 i like that
move
now frankly if i don't do something
weird i should just
crash here once again because of the
open files
let me play i don't know queen a5 maybe
yeah the benco vocal gambit it's a great
opening conceptually and i've never seen
the king castling right into it
the bishop on j7 and the rook on the b
file is going to hit the beats upon
and the king is going to be deeply hurt
let's see let's see
there is some discussion there about the
indian
defenses yeah you see i like that i'm
offering you some food for thought i
feel that's what i should be doing
in general i like when
people just give each other something to
think about
share their thoughts and setting each
other
to think is something we should all be
doing
and here i have set my opponent a
question posting a question on
how is he going to protect his c4 pawn
and he decided to not do that at all
that is a big mistake because now i'm
taking a c4 and i'm
doing a little double attack
oh he decided to resign okay thank you
for the game